what up anime fans its goes on and kid
Kai and we're here to talk about episode
43 of Dragon Ball super kit Kai what are
your initial thoughts my initial
thoughts well honestly the episodes
that's it's terrible it's it's really
[ __ ] bad I'm not gonna lie like if
there was ever anything in super that
was a filler this is it but it's not a
complete disaster
there are were a few things to point out
I do like one of the things that I saw
was I love Pan's love for piccolo that
he does she clearly inherited from her
father Gohan who also had a love for
piccolo and I loved that pickles now the
world's strongest babysitter
yeah well Wow yeah I don't know about
strongest but please he's yeah he's he's
the best like he's really cool
babysitter ed and it has been funny
though I just pick a little girl and
this is not gonna be let's say the most
interesting in regards to action which
is what Dragon Ball Z is known for right
but at the same time we do get a bunch
of characterization this episode which
although is definitely filler and
somewhat ridiculous at times it's
interesting because we see piccolo yeah
he's definitely growing with pan and
he's definitely he loves her it's clear
and it's sold the scene is awesome where
he knows all these things he knows how
she likes her food she knows that
carrots go before everything else and he
knows he knows everything about taking
care of pan and then when he goes to
leave he came and bring himself to leave
and he ends up just saying cuz he can't
you know can't doesn't want to leave
doesn't want us out great himself from
her yeah so obviously like we love that
part you know we can't deny that it's
it's weird coke Goku's key stuff is
weird because we assume like why don't
they just take a sense of being like if
what we know about sense of beans so far
is true then that would fix everything
but I guess since he hasn't thought of
it
you know it may be just a new instance
of Goku stupidity and super or
that family made him even more stupid
than he was easy but the thing is
there's also other methods for healing
him if the sense will being doesn't work
then they can heal also kabhi Tokai can
heal yeah I guess they just it's not
like I don't even think it's the point
of the can do like if this is like an
action action episode like you
definitely you definitely get him healed
but I guess they wanted to explore some
different parts of his character so
they're like okay this guy is always
fighting is always strong let's take
away his strength for a little while so
we can go back to a later and now let's
let's go his family side cuz we haven't
really seen him like you know it's not
sure really about family but I did like
it because it kind of shows that even
without his strength you know he called
himself an old grandpa and pickles like
Goku you are an old grandpa so that was
funny and it shows how you you know
there's more to life than fighting and
he saw that and he saw he was surprised
that he could enjoy a day without
training you know there's more to life
than training and and that was
interesting and what was interesting for
me was how Gohan turned down that
position to be a process system like I
think that was great because we that
means he'll probably have more time for
training you know he said for pan but at
the same time I I feel like the more he
moves away from that scholarly world the
more he's gonna be drawn to the training
world right right and I agree because he
doesn't have to be taking care of pan
the whole time especially with piccolo
being around and obviously Vidal Pan's
mother and Hercule yeah her killed that
fight Hercule is their majin buu ER has
miss her killed
I don't know if I trust what do you
trust watching with your baby no you
wouldn't trust margin boom with your
baby but he's there with Hercule all the
time so he's gonna be around the kid but
he has shown a caring inside when he
saved that puppy and Dragon Ball Z but
that's a different story that's besides
the point of this episode um yeah yeah
it's it's it's interesting is just a
very terrible transition I like that
they try and do some character
development outside of fighting but the
transition was gone
like like I wanna yeah its doctrines
it's not believable like I don't know
it's not really believable Goku's injury
like I feel I get sort of like that's
cool if you want to explore the human
side of Goku cuz you know this other
side is almost like the same side and
now we're getting some of the some of
the same humanity side and if we want to
apply the humanity thing to an alien
well I assume we can because we've seen
we can in other ways like love and like
like all this other stuff but yes so
what we're seeing we're seeing a human
in quotes side of Goku which is cool
like I'm definitely down to explore that
let's see there's also pan and her doing
crazy action this episode so right yeah
I'm gonna peel off peel off was
unnecessary peel off and crew was
unnecessary well I hope they are never
brought back into super they're so
necessary and so stupid I even thought
they were stupid and Dragon Ball when
they were actually dangerous let alone
now yeah peel off so peel off nothing a
joke and like when you see him you know
it's either comic relief or just filler
like really bad comic relief it's a
vehicle through which to explore other
things and I mean like I said last up so
we can't take these episodes seriously
but it was interesting to talk about a
pan and her power right so we get peel
off who along with this crew
accidentally kidnapped pan and then
after that they end up you know she ends
up pulling her pants right [ __ ] her
pants and everything her phone's gonna
change her diapers and stuff
yeah and then they freak out cuz they
can't open a window and then they end up
in space so whatever and then somehow
she unleashes some incredible hidden
potential I like one and a half years
which what I wanted to talk about was
two implications which even though like
the episode itself is kind of out there
like the implications would be
interesting
Gohan we knew had hidden potential right
and like amazing like more potential
than Goku and Vegeta so what's
interesting is pan is shown to have even
more potential to go on than at that age
right no one would think that her flying
could be possible no one would think
that her powering up at this point could
be possible and apparent that she can
breathe in space now switch I thought
only like a Super Saiyan God could do
but whatever yeah yeah that's besides
the point but so it seems like two less
saying you are the more powerful your
potential is which is kind of wrong no I
I think it's actually extraordinarily
stupid 5050 made sense as potential
because you pick up both characteristics
but you're becoming so diluted that
you're losing that sand thing and humans
are much much much weaker than sands who
in turn are much weaker than the gods
but that's besides the point is my point
is is her potential is I think highly
exaggerated if she's only quarter
percents and I think she should have
less potential than full blooded Saiyan
as well as half blooded sands but
whatever it's yeah well we don't know
how that works right we don't know the
biology works like I maybe there's
something in saying DNA which reacts
good to human DNA and so the more human
you are the more stronger it feeds into
the science I'd I'm not sure like we
don't really know but it's definitely
suggesting that and if you have listened
to feed into Hsinchu power technically
be weaker no because the Pens how it
works right I mean yes 1/100 has a super
saiyan is we seen we've seen that pure
super saiyan isn't isn't as good as
Super Saiyan mixed with humans so the
hybrid is the ultimate form
well maybe not well depends depends if
you want to take into movies then Broly
a full blooded Saiyan has the largest
potential by far scene yeah but it's
still lost cuz he's son
yeah well that movie a lot of people
don't like it I like it I don't care
yeah anyways I just don't like this like
[ __ ] Vegeta being scared yeah like
this spot being scared yeah just like
like why are you going from prideful
blonde second to the scare this little
[ __ ] the other side it wasn't scared of
Frieza I don't know why the [ __ ] he is
scared of everybody else all of a sudden
well I think it was a huge difference he
should she shouldn't be scared of
beetles and he definitely shouldn't be
like any more like whatever I get he's
strong but yeah there's a balance
between that they should strike between
carefree Goku and like off so scared
Regina
anyways Goku saw bomas sagging breasts
comments on that good cut funniest scene
by far in the episode it made me giggle
that I'd go for appears and hers I
thought he'd appear in some random
woman's apartments yeah honey it would
ensue which would have been better
writing but again we didn't know what
the [ __ ] oddball mafia boma running
into Goku and then her being embarrassed
that he saw her sagging breasts even
though in Dragon Ball II seen her naked
at least like a million times even
though a million when they were perky
right but I I mean I feel bad like stop
talking about bomas sagging breasts is
also embarrassed at the same time again
Gina feeling all these silly emotions
well but it's not silly I mean you don't
want you know why your arrival to see
your wife's boobs right right you don't
but at the same time it's like he's
supposed to be this like guy that's not
overly caring and then like you should
he should have made like a smartass
remark about towards him as opposed to
just going red I don't know why Vegeta
went red yeah well again we're seeing
now like a more humane side of Aegina
too so that's their really maybe it
shows that culture is king rather than
biology because these guys are becoming
a lot more human than we'd have expected
well right but at the same time it's
like I don't understand how they're
losing a lot of these same
characteristics which are ingrained in
their DNA such as like
Vegeta used to be the badass Prince of
Sands now he is like he's certain pick
up on bad human qualities like I don't
know how I don't know if it's bad man
like it's funny but I wouldn't say it's
bad okay like him being scared of every
other character that's not that's that's
definitely the same he was always he was
like that way before like that Broly
movie is not why but why is he dancing
when beerus comes to entertain him like
you yeah i don't get well why is [ __ ]
Vegeta wearing aprons like they're using
him too much for humor like that they're
hurting his character man like but Jesus
[ __ ] cool man like you guys should
check out our top 10 like coolest Dragon
Ball super characters like what Gina is
[ __ ] cool and they shouldn't like
[ __ ] be emasculating Haman [ __ ]
no I agree with you and it's just pure
silliness of what they're doing of
making him seem weaker and weaker in
terms of character but whatever I'm not
writing this so we're just judging but
yeah like we're saying like we're not
gonna be too too crazy and harsh about
like these filler episodes which they
definitely are like some people were
thinking oh maybe it's not filler maybe
should be considered filler I think it
definitely should well it definitely
should be considered filler aminos it's
not it's much lower than what we usually
get from super and supers I like super
super can be received in general a good
grade in terms of anime writing quality
and other things like that
but this episode is just so so bad for
me like yeah we're all like a 4 out of
10 personally and that's the worst I've
given for a super episode it was you
know it's a filler whatever I hope they
don't last long I am looking forward to
the one that they announced where
they're gonna visit planet Vegeta in
universe 6 - and they're gonna meet
Kaabah and potentially other sands and
that is gonna have a lot of content in
my opinion to talk about I'm definitely
excited about that this this next the
previous ode was still building off of
the fact that Goku does not have full
use of his power and it seemed like we
shouldn't get our hopes up but you know
we'll see you again with these episodes
most focusing on the humor and it's and
it's it's worth it like it's worth
watching like I enjoyed it and me and
kid car joking around a lot with it but
yeah I mean what Dragonball does best is
fighting and unfortunately slice-of-life
they do that it's an action anime man
that's what I always liked about it is
an action anime I go for action I don't
go for other things if I want
slice-of-life I'll go watch cannot and
cannot after story if I want you to fall
if i won well right one of the most
well-rounded anime I'd go watch Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood you know
what I mean if I want a motivating anime
I'll go watch Gurren Lagann and stuff
like that but I think and generally
should just stick to what they do best
and alright alright final thoughts final
thoughts again guys this is not best
Dragon Ball super but it's funny don't
take it too seriously what about you
think I yeah I agree with you honestly
just don't judge the whole show by this
this episode anyways alright like I said
I give it a 4 out of 10 not bad it has
some funny scenes but that's about it
for me alright guys so that was episode
43 review you should also check out our
top 10 coolest Dragon Ball super
characters and we'll see you next time
All Right see you later space cowboys